this is a robot that walks flies
skateboards and slacklines
but why
[Music]
a portion of this video was sponsored by
bluehost more about them at the end of
the show
there are lots of bipedal robots out
there and drones are ubiquitous but
until now no one had engineered walking
and flying technology to work together
in a single robot so it's the first
robot that truly integrates the walking
and the flying it's it's not just a
drone with legs
these are leonardo and it stands for
legs on board drone so i think it's a
pretty good name why is this potentially
useful yeah so any flying vehicles
actually have to start from the ground
to take off and eventually they cannot
stay in the air forever they have to
eventually come down but sometimes they
have to come down on the very
challenging terrain or some obstacles so
it's actually a good idea to have these
controllable lags so they can actually
land in a very
interesting configuration or posture or
orientation
but there are additional benefits a
robot like this is more stable than a
regular drone i view these propellers
almost like our arms so some people
might say that oh you guys are cheating
because i mean bipedal robots do not
have propellers but we are essentially
using the propellers to do additional
stabilization
[Applause]
[Music]
so basically you generate the lift or
thrust of course to cancel the somewhat
the weight of the robot but that's
really a secondary fact the most
important thing is basically posture or
orientation stabilization
[Music]
so the main facility for this lab is
this one it's a gigantic fennel way i
can see all the fans now yeah we have uh
you can't start counting but 1296
computer fans those are really literally
computer fast how fast can it generate
wind so up to 15 meter per second or 20
meter per second it's like a wind tunnel
without the need for a tunnel yes it
might mess with our audio or with our
microphones whoa
the idea of this smog machine is to
actually visualize the flow but also you
know these additional sensors like
infrared cameras or radar and lidar how
we can actually figure out the kind of
location or environment around your
vehicle in the presence of this
bug
and i wanted to feel their power for
myself
all right you ready yeah let's do it
that was so cool
i love it
they used this facility to test leonardo
to see how stable he is even in
different wind conditions
and we showed that leo is more robust
than a drone because the drone gets
blown away by the wind but then leo does
not because of its ground contact so for
example if you go hiking and there's
like suddenly a lot of wind you're not
going to fall because you have the
ground contact but for a drone it might
be blown away
[Music]
oh no
so we actually took one of the white
boards that we have at home and we put
oil so we applied perturbations to leo
and what's happening is as you push leo
instead of falling it stays upright but
it also slides on the white board so
that's an interesting capability so it's
very robust you said perturbations are
you poking the robot yes without harming
the robot we are gentle
[Music]
leonardo is so stable and good at
adjusting its balance that it can
skateboard
[Music]
that's a that's a fancy trick
not many people can go backwards on a
skateboard
how did you get the idea for a robot
that will skateboard should i say the
truth or make a nice story uh tell us
the truth yeah so uh we went hiking and
we saw about 10 people going down the
mountain on a skateboard and then we
thought wow this is really cool what if
we try our robots to make it do this
so we went to the first shop and we
bought a skateboard we modified it and
we tried it and it worked so do you
think it allows the robot to save energy
by riding on a skateboard it's more
efficient because it uses the legs less
the legs are basically used to steer and
then it's just the propellers that i use
to accelerate the skateboard forward and
backwards so yeah it makes it save a bit
more energy the propellers of course
make it possible to skateboard backwards
something i struggled with
i definitely would help if i had a
propeller
but the real challenge was slacklining
[Music]
this looks incredibly unstable so i
think this proves the point of just like
how important control systems are you
can tell from the footage i have no idea
what i'm doing
all right i thought i would be slightly
better at that let's give it another
shot
okay
can anyone slackline
this is impossible i need a robot to do
this for me
[Music]
i like the side stepping technique
maybe i should have been doing that
trying to like copy his technique
[Music]
i tried to get some tips by watching
leonardo
[Music]
but improvement was negligible
i should have prepared
you might think it's cheating to use
propellers but the robot is clearly not
flying it is supporting itself mostly
using the rope and it's able to
stabilize itself even with the wild
bouncing
so human professionals like liner if you
see some of their videos actually they
use their arm stretched and then they
can balance themselves we don't have the
arms for leo yet we are planning to add
a manipulation
for that it can actually carry some
object but in the meantime we are using
the propellers to stabilize the allele
while it's actually working on a slack
line it's funny because like the robot
feels like it's got kind of a
personality to it the way it walks and
flies yeah right it's just totally
something you're not used to seeing yeah
it looks natural actually i have to say
that the sensors are sampled at 1000
times per second but the controller is
actually being recomputed whatever
signal you're sending to propellers and
the left joints 200 times per second so
it's pretty fast like a computation 200
times a second it is adjusting what it's
doing to maintain balance yes like
especially propeller control signal how
does that compare to humans
oh humans
so humans
can do very sophisticated tasks but in
terms of a fast reaction it's very crude
machine so
humans in overall has a few seconds of
delay time delay is this why i was
struggling on the slack line but maybe
how do you feel about the performance
here today yeah i think it beat you
i mean not that that's hard but this is
very impressive
if you imagine a robot like leonardo in
the future like the greatest
leonardo you could make
what would that robot look like and do
so definitely having a leo like robot in
space that would be amazing but of
course depending on where you go you
might not be able to use propellers so
then you would need to use thrusters so
eventually yes we want to develop this
lag based
adaptive landing gear and then we give
that to next generation mars helicopter
or next generation flying cars so that
it can actually land in very challenging
condition and still move around once
again and then once yeah once you land
then you can walk over
if you have a cliff and then you have
the robot just jump out of the cliff
deploy the propellers and fly
that'd be wild
oh hey there
this portion of the video was sponsored
by bluehost you know tech is now so
advanced that robots can skateboard so
why is it still so hard to build a
website make the process simple with
bluehost it's easier than ever to get
started bluehost provides you with a
completely free domain for the first
year as well as quick start templates so
you can have a beautiful website up and
running in just minutes the templates
are mobile ready so your website is
optimized for both phones and computers
from the start unlike the process of
building a robot like leo you don't need
code in order to make your website
bluehost lets you customize everything
with simple drag and drop editing and
bluehost builder also allows people to
choose their own editing journey it's
built on wordpress so at any time you
can toggle between wordpress core the
traditional editing experience and the
bluehost builder with no loss of
functionality this is a first of its
kind builder experience so start
building your website today with
bluehost just go to bluehost.com track
veritasium to receive more than 65 off i
will put that link down in the
description so i want to thank bluehost
again for sponsoring this portion of the
video and i want to thank you for
watching